Speaker 1: Now, one thing that is not going
well for Donald Trump. Is his much promoted
new social media communications platform. I
call it a blog, it's already been shut down.
I guess it lasted about twenty nine days. This
is so embarrassing. Months spent promoting what's
basically just a glorified, glorified, glorified,
glorified blogspot page on his Donald J. Trump
dotcom site. It's gone. The page from the desk of
Donald Trump has been scrubbed from the website
and it, quote, will not be returning, according
to Donald Trump's senior lackey, Jason Miller.
If you try to access the page now, it just
redirects you to a sign up for his mailing list.
So what happened here? I think it's
really simple. It failed miserably.
Nobody was reading it. It was barely getting any
attention. No one cared about it. It was doing
nothing positive for Donald Trump. So it looks bad
to have something up that's not doing well. And so
Trump took it down. And now it's also possible
to put the most positive possible spin on this.
It's possible that because Trump is allegedly
restarting his MAGGA rallies later this month,
he's just shifting to a different means
of communication. Via email, Trump lackey
Jason Miller downplayed that they were ever
making a big deal out of this. He said, quote,
It was just auxillary to the broader efforts we
have and are working on. But anyone who remembers
the period between Trump's Twitter ban and the
launch of the blog knows they were promoting
this thing as if it was going to be God's gift
to humanity, this blog, and had it gone well,
they would still be talking about it and promoting
it in that way. Now, hilariously, they are sort
of, again, going back to promoting something
even bigger. This is so funny. On Twitter,
Amy Tarkanian, the former Nevada Republican
congresswoman chairwoman, tweeted, The desk of
Donald Trump section of Trump's website has been
removed and will not be returning. Perhaps this
is a precursor to him joining another social
media platform to which Jason Miller replied,
Yes, actually, it is. Stay tuned. It's all
pathetic. It's all a failure in total. It lasted
about a month and it's gone. And genuinely,
though, I was never interested in the blog,
I am interested in the upcoming rallies
because we've been wondering, you know,
what's the future of the Republican Party? What's
the mood of the GOP heading into 2022? I think
interviews with rally goers in June, July and
August are going to give us the first real
insight into the mood of the average Trump, at
least to some degree. As far as the blog itself,
I actually think it's more likely that it wasn't
the non-existent Web traffic that Trump was so
pissed off at. I think Trump was mad that
the posts weren't making news for almost
five years. Trump would tweet and it would be news
in real time on all the major cable networks and
all over the place. Trump was I mean, almost every
day there was a headline based on a Trump tweet.
And then Trump has this blog and it's just not
making any headlines. And I mean, honestly, Trump
not tweeting for the first few weeks that he
was off Twitter made more news than anything
Trump ever published to this blog. So it came
and went. I guess it's let's see, a Scaramucci
is is a Scaramouch in ten days. How long Anthony
Scaramucci lasted. So twenty nine days would be
like about three Scaramouch is worth and it
is gone much to the delight of many people